hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
torten wild heute gibt es ein rezept aus
unserem letzten türkei urlaub ihr wisst
ja wir gehen da ganz gern im hin und man
kann da richtig gut frühstücken in der
türkei und da gab's ein brot so in der
pfanne gebacken was wir total lecker
fanden und zwar ist es broadcast und
cutman heißt eigentlich so viel wie
zusammengefaltet
ich hatte auch mal dieser kath.net
porsche also diese brötchen und das ist
praktisch wie so ja das ist so ein
blätterteig aber kein blätterteig und da
entstehen einfach so verschiedene
schichten durchschnitt durch seine
technik zeige ich gleich und ist jetzt
praktischen brot aus der pfanne was ihr
zum frühstück servieren können oder
einfach mal mittags also bei den türken
ist auch so da gibt es mittags zum tee
salate und also eher so herzhaft es
nichts süßes und mehr so herzhafte
kleine kreis kurabi plätzchen und ja
dass ich auch so was was sie da machen
können eine zeitung hat es dich nicht
schon mal gemacht das video
nein sicher ich habe nun mal gebacken
ohne cover gehabt er sagte kein wir
waren letzten sieben jahren drei mal 10
aber wenn mir halt in urlaub gehen 73
mal im urlaub
ja na ja vielleicht schaffen was oft na
ja jetzt zeige ich euch malkurse zutaten
im prinzip sind grundzutaten ihr braucht
nur eine zutat die ihr vielleicht nicht
zu hause habe die zeit aber jetzt als
ich habe hier 125 milliliter milch 125
milliliter wasser das ich handwarm ich
habe hier ein päckchen trockenhefe das
entspricht einem halben würfel hefe also
könnte auch frische hefe
dann habe ich hier ein teelöffel zucker
einen teelöffel salz 600 gramm mehl und
ich brauche etwas tag eben sesampaste
das brauchen wir gleich für den
geschmack wer jetzt vielleicht kein tag
in geschmacklich möchte dem empfehle ich
es erstmal trotzdem und was wirklich gar
nicht nehmen möchte der kann auch zb
später etwas butter nehmen oder etwas
gouda oder sie sind türkischen kaffee
durchaus und gouda und das schmeckt auch
richtig
aber ich muss heute mittag hin weil mir
das ja es ist einfach orientalische
nämlich erstmal die hefe und ich habe
auch keine frische hilfe da deswegen
trockenhefe so die gebe ich ins warme
wasser gemeinsam mit dem zucker
verrühren kurz
geht es dann direkt in die
küchenmaschine könnte den teig auch
natürlich mit der hand kneten
aber so geht es für mich einfach
einfacher und schneller
auflösen
dann gebe ich direkt auf mail mit dazu
aber nicht komplett alles für den ersten
teil die mädels ein solcher grund dir
ein tolles rainer ja also beihilfe ist
halt so da gibt man halt am anfang kein
fett dazu und mich hat ja auch fett und
deswegen muss ich die hilfe immer ein
wasser auf und gibt sogar mit reingeht
sie besser auf da können sich diese hefe
bakterien diese kulturen war eben
verlängern überführen egal
jede dritte
dass man diesen verkneten jetzt gebe ich
einfach noch mehr mehl dazu auf das salz
nicht vergessen
und der teig ist fertig wenn er sich
ganz einfach vom schlüssel rand ablöst
und zu seinem wald zusammenkommt das ist
jetzt kein weicher hefeteig sondern mehr
so ein festerer ich habe jetzt auch etwa
550 gramm mehl benutzt müsste einfach
mal schauen dass ich auch ein türkisches
rezept da wo das ursprünglich mit
gläsern abgemessen
und ich hab sagt für euch müssen
umgerechnet jetzt nehme ich den teig so
ein bisschen zusammen formen zu einer
kugel gibt dann etwas mailen die
schüssel
und bedeckt es ganz auch nochmal mit
nähe und deckt die schüssel jetzt gleich
ab und lasst den teig geht's erst mal
auf gehen ja so bis es sich etwa
verdoppelt hat das mache ich jetzt kurz
im ausgeschalteten backofen des so auf
40 grad erhitzt und dann gehts auch
gleich wieder weiter
der hefeteig gesetz aufgegangen und ich
stets wieder hier auf meiner ähnlich auf
männer sondern an meiner holz
arbeitsplatte und wehl die leicht und
gibt auch den teig drauf alle rechte
noch mit drauf und der teig ist schön
geschmeidig aber ebene zu weich und den
teile ich mir jetzt ein innen herrscht
also in sechs portionen als halbieren
und dann drittel mehrmals
dann vorm ich das so ganz leicht zu
welchen kann es nämlich gleich schöne
ausrollen
jetzt auch am besten wer zu viel mehl
einarbeiten es nämlich immer härter
datei
dann nehme ich mir das erste belchen und
wollte es einfach noch so groß aus wie
es geht
also so groß wie es halt mit einem
nudelholz hier geht mir im haus hall
starb
und jetzt kommt dieser saison passte ins
spiel denn die wird jetzt rein
gestrichen und die ich ja auch ziemlich
fertig deswegen eignet die sich ganz gut
und der geschmack erschallt wirklich
richtig schön orientalisch und so ein
esslöffel hier ein richtiges la mer und
dann mit dem pinsel einfach schön
verteilen
aber so dass es schön dann damit bedeckt
ist
das ganze wird dann jetzt aufgerollt
und dann noch zu einer schnecke gefreut
es drücke ich jetzt ein bisschen flach
und lasst es kurz hier an der seite
steht und verarbeitet erst mal die
anderen genauso weit
ich habe jetzt hier alle sechs schon
ausgerollt und zur schnecke
zusammengerollt jetzt werden die noch
mal ausgerollt und zwar so groß wie hat
eure pfanne ist also bei mir sind es so
ungefähr 28 cm oder sogar ganz genau 28
steht nämlich drauf und jetzt rolle ich
das brot schön flach aus und durch diese
schneckenform kommt dann auch später
dieser flat ricke effekt und deswegen
macht dann sind es halt so einzelne
schichten die nacheinander so zu
abblättern voll lecker dass bruder hat
mich immer gleich an der urlaub damit
dass immer dahinter meinen kaffee
gegessen haben zum frühstück also so
groß und ich finde es hat ja auch eine
schöne optik durch dieses
schneckenförmigen so wissel marmoriert
und die rolle ich jetzt nacheinander aus
und kann ihn derzeit schon mal die
pfanne erhitzen einfach ohne fett
die pfanne ist jetzt schön heiß und ich
habe da kein fett mit drin
jetzt gebe ich das brot da rein und dann
könnte das bei so etwa mittel hoher
hitze schön anbraten
ich denke es braucht von jeder seite so
etwa fünf minuten drei bis fünf minuten
müsste einfach mal unten kontrollieren
und dann hole ich sie gleich raus und
bestreicht sind noch mit butter so kann
sich die türkei und ich riecht schon mal
so ein bisserl was dazu was ich mit dazu
anrichte
jetzt für streiche ich schon mal die
eine seite bisher mit butter das müsste
jetzt nicht machen aber dadurch wird es
brot natürlich auch ein bisschen
saftiger und wie ich finde noch lecker
und man sieht jetzt auch hier ganz
deutlich diese diese blätter die jetzt
hier so entstehen ins wort und jetzt
nehme ich einen teller und gibt es schön
darauf die seite bestreite ich auch
gleich mit öl und butter
aber ich mag jetzt in der zeit schon mal
die nächsten aus
als ich habe schon mal ein paar tomaten
gehören beim türkischen frühstück immer
mit dazu was natürlich auch nicht fehlen
darf ist etwas käse da habe ich jetzt
hier diesen weichkäse also dass ich es
keine väter der ich nicht aus
schafsmilch sondern aus chrom in den
schneide ich ein bisschen
es hat echt immer mit der zuweisung
wirklich frühstück sind übrigens meine
schäden diesmal aus der türkei geholt
habe
dann natürlich auch ein paar schwarze
oliven da mag ich ganz gern stelle
also das ist eine besondere art der
zubereitung die werden glaube ich mit
salz ein bisschen entwässert und eben
haltbar gemacht so schöne kleine was
auch ganz gut dazu passt dass endlich
auch stahl an die türkei sind
rosenblätter in sirup finde ich auch
total gut ist zwar sehr süß aber dass
körper zu hinter türkei also da kann man
ja auch marmeladen uns weiter nicht
weniger süß machen weil sie dann nicht
haltbar sind
gerade bei der hitze die dort herrscht
ganz tollen geschmack gute sieht man
jetzt wieder in kaum
aber das sind halt so einzelne
rosenblätter in sirup und dann nach
samira lieblings aufstrich dann nehme
ich jetzt auch wieder diese sesampaste
und vermischt die gleich mit etwas sirup
dahin es nennt sich das dann
und da gibt's jetzt entweder und trauten
sirup oder hals und maulbeeren sirup je
nachdem was euch halt besser schmeckt
könnt ihr dann eben ich finde beides
sehr gut ab heute nämlich mal den
baumberg sirup und von dem gebe ich
jetzt auch mit rein dann erstmal
verrühren
und wenn es dann so diese farbe hat also
was wir schon dass so ein bisschen
karamell farben
dann ist auch süß genug also der diese
dann passt ist ja nicht so süß die ich
neutral schmeckte nach saison hat und
der trauben zurück es hat relativ süß
und er müsste einfach mal abgleichen und
einfach probieren ihr euch das am besten
schmeckt mir schmeckt es auf brot
richtig gut ich tue einfach immer so
brotstücke reihen so kleine fladenbrot
stücke oder eben auf diesem pfad mit
brot jetzt mache ich noch schnell die
brote fertig setzt meint ihr noch auf
und dann gibt's gleich frühstück meine
brote sind fast alle ausgebacken 1 habe
ich jetzt noch aber ich sehe das jetzt
schon mal denn ich bekomme heute
besuchte frühstück und die sind auch
schon da und deswegen mache ich schnell
hier mit euch fertig also es gibt jetzt
diese kaputt brote und dazu diese sachen
ich stell natürlich auch gleich noch
normale brötchen mit dazu weil ich ja
bezahlt so viel brot gemacht und dazu
gibt es ganz traditionell ein türkischer
tee lässt zu dunkel und das wäre ich
jetzt gleich meinen gästen und gelassen
und sie gleich schmecken
ich zeige euch jetzt nur ganz kurz
einmal was ich meinte mit diesem
abblättern also man sieht es jetzt hier
auch deutlich man kann das hier einfach
abreißen und dieses brot teilt sich
daneben auf in dieser einzelnen
schichten und es kommt eben durch diese
schnecke und durch das aufrollen zu
stande und schmeckt halt echt richtig
lecker und locker und dann kann man das
entweder hier in die rosenheimer laden
rein drucken oder mit dem twin pack -
also mit dem sesam trauben gemisch
peißen oder eben ganz normal mit nutella
bestreichen oder mit dem käse belegen
also egal so wie er es möchte
bei uns ist auch so also ich frühstück
ganz gerne immer gemischt das heißt bei
uns gibt sich und süß alles zusammen und
ich auf meinen teller von nutella brot
gemeinsam mit dem käse oder mit anderen
sachen
so bin ich halt aufgewachsen zu essen
wir das zu hause und in der türkei eben
auch und ihr könnt es jetzt gerne
nachmachen das rezept steht auf
cellestis blog.de und ich freue mich
wenn ihr das nächste mal wieder
einschaltet und wünsche euch ganz viel
spaß beim nachmachen bis dahin